[Music]
good
[Music]
[Applause]
hey everybody what's going on bobby here
with you in the geek culture studios you
just saw the announcement from fujifilm
we have in our hands with us today the
first impressions of the gfx 50s mark ii
with my good friend ivan here who is an
uh fujifilm ambassador in singapore so
we're going to run you through the
camera specs what it's like to use
because we actually both use this for
the yes that's right a number of
undisclosed weeks
yes we can't say yeah we can't say how
long we've been having this camera can
we it's a secret it's a secret yeah
we'll talk about the new lens of course
the 3570 and various different lenses on
the 50s mark ii so with that before we
kick off this video message from our
sponsors paying the bills for us
logitech this video is brought to you by
logitech here at geek culture gaming is
a way of life and we always enjoy
dishing out headshots with logitech g
pro x super light mouse the lightweight
wireless mouse combines excellent
performance with classy no frills look
designed with pros and engineered to win
it offers crisp and responsive clicks
the smooth operator even allows you to
swap out the magnetic dongle storage
compartment for greater gliding ease
check out all of its other features over
at logitechg.com
all right guys before we kick things off
i do want to let you know we are not
paid or sponsored for this even though
ivan's a fujifilm ambassador i'm not
i do use the 100s though quite a bit for
a lot of the work i do so i'm a fan of
the 100s uh but yes these are kind of
our thoughts and our thoughts only on it
so let's let's talk about the 50s mark
ii ivan what do you think which one is
the mach 2 yeah that's the question
which one is the partner
okay the only difference is um
i think yeah yeah this little
mark ii 50s mark two logo on it other
than that
they're basically
exactly the same exactly the same there
are no difference in terms of the size
weight design
i actually weight on my wife's um green
color kitchen scale they're actually the
same that's the official skill by the
way yeah for me yeah because whatever
the wife skill says is correct exactly
at all times so that's the thing about
this camera i think that uh obviously
the leaks and the rumors have been out
there for quite some time and you know
this body design is fantastic i mean
with the 100s i mean the ergonomics are
great uh the weight distribution
everything else is there um but
it still has that same 50 megapixel
sensor that we have from the original
50s right yes and the 50r
but
it now has a new body uh either upgraded
yes there's ibis upgraded features
it basically works the same exactly like
the gfx100s
with some missing feature of course
right because this is still
contrast-based autofocusing yes that's
right and this is a face yeah yeah which
is something that a lot of people were
asking in on the rumor mills is it going
to have phase detect
and the answer is no unfortunately yes
that's right but they do have a feature
called um rapid af that's right yeah
it's supposed to help during
dark moments i think right yeah because
contrast-based focusing up for those of
you used it obviously we use the
original 50s and the 50r yeah you know i
mean in bright daylight it focuses quick
it's responsive or and when you have a
definite contrast from your subject or
whatever you can really frame it but
when in a dark situation it's times a
bit yeah yeah so this feature actually
helps a little bit more
yep
so now ivan actually even though you're
an ambassador you are primarily a gfx
shooter right yes correct so what did
you start off with first i mean out of
the first camera systems for gfx yeah i
started with gx50s uh mach 1 and then
from there i moved the
gfx 100s okay yeah i skipped 100 because
i thought it was a bit too big for my
liking okay
so now that you've you've cause you've
got a chance to play with this quite a
bit
when you have not as long as you well
that's because you were very kind
[Laughter]
but when you played with this a bit
obviously you're coming from the 50s
what were some of the things that i
think a lot of people would they want to
know is there a big difference did you
notice a difference in terms of the
performance
um af is definitely more better
definitely to certain extent it's better
okay um low light of course it can't
beat the gfx 100s that's that's the
reality of it but in terms of the
ergonomics i like it because it's the
same as the gfx 100s
other than that it's a useful camera if
you compare this to the gfx 50s mark one
i love this small of course it looks
more modern yeah there's no pop-up back
you know for the cooling system
um now pair the new 3570 i think it's a
very nice little comfortable package
it's not light of course but in the gfx
world this is pretty light or probably
the lightest you could get i mean even a
medium format for that matter because
you know when you think about medium
format cameras they're always just
massive i mean even when we talked in
2016 when the 50s came out and of course
i mean there was the hasselblad x1d yeah
which is a smaller body but
uh you know
uniform has always been a much bigger
system so the bring it into a size like
this which is basically the size of a
full frame camera yes is quite an
astounding feat it is it is i mean for
for someone who uses what they call full
frame if they're thinking of moving up
to
a
minimum format this is probably a good
choice for start yeah based on the size
at even the price point right because
it's coming at 4 000 us dollars yes i'm
cut off i mean yeah that's
mind-blowing for medium format i mean
you know just a couple years ago we were
looking at
five digits yeah easy yeah easy and so
the lens coming around 500 us dollars
for that the body about 4 000 so about 4
500 usd
for a medium format system now yes if
you want to compare that to full frame
there can be a discussion which we'll
talk about probably later on this video
in regards to that but for medium format
that is a game changer i've been playing
with this camera for a while too and
i mean i have to say the build quality
versus the 50 s2 if you haven't tried
the 100s it's so much better yes
definitely so much better yes i do miss
though the vertical grip on the 50s yeah
the grip was really nice it was a really
nice grip i think fujifilm knocked it
out of the park with that one um there
is no vertical grip for this for the 50s
ii or the 100s so and you just get a
little plate plate at the extension of
that that's basically which i actually
want to try that plate have you tried
the plate i have not i want to try that
plate we're gonna go pick one up and try
that out but um besides that though i
mean everything feels good you've got
all the same ports on this you've got
your hdmi ports you've got your usb-c
port you know dual sd card slots on this
there's no difference at all to the 100s
nothing yeah so i guess it comes down to
image quality and price i mean really
what is this who's this for and yeah
yeah 15 megapixels different and 2 000
usd difference yeah that's the topic
actually that's really the topic of this
whole video i think you could say
because this lens in its own right is a
basic kit lens we'll talk about the
performance but that is a question i
want to ask you
because
you know
um 4000 versus 6000 usd right
i mean in 2016
when this sensor first came out
i mean
full frame cameras weren't really at
that level yet right we're now in 2021
it's still the same sensor
but a lot of cameras like you know let's
say
sony 7r4 the r5 from canon the alpha one
you know
uh uh nikon with the z7 in
two i mean
how do you think this fits into the game
i think maybe the strategy has to do
with pricing first of all
because in 2016 when they launch it it's
probably like i don't know
it was the eight triple nice thing
dollars what was it 10 it was about 10 i
think around 10 right 10 000 singapore
dollars right because the house will buy
was more expensive around 12 i think
right yeah so now it's actually probably
half the price
or probably 60 of the original selling
price and now you get a new camera
imagine you're looking for a used gfx
50s why would you want to buy that and
you can buy this that's true at probably
the same price that's true yeah so the
question is about the sensor do you need
more if you do need more then it's the
two thousand dollars worth and upgrade
and that's the question because now you
can use the kids camera professionally
right
you went from a 50 to 100 yes
how often do you really need 100
megapixels
honestly speaking
i'm not a very honest person yeah
um
i usually shoot 100 of course obviously
but there are times i don't need 100 of
course
but it's good to have it for work i feel
you have the power to crop it yeah
that's uh it makes your work more
forgiving if your client wants it a bit
tighter you're able to crop right yeah
but not that 50 megapixel is bad it's
also good if you can crop it but the
question to me is always a two thousand
dollar difference would i spend at two
thousand dollars yeah would you
professionally i would spend two
thousand dollars more to get the gfx 100
because of the cropping power yes file
size yes the ef okay yeah yeah the af is
a big thing on me because i mean we're
talking let's talk about performance
real quick in that because
uh
that's the one thing i noticed a big
difference of when i put them back to
back is that
the af
on the gfx100s is
i mean you just don't see that on medium
format it's always been contrast based
even with a phase phase one camera
system it's a single point you know it's
slow that's right you know and that's a
70 000 camera system right this is phase
detect rivaling some you know full frame
like what you mentioned before
for a medium format camera autofocus as
much as the 50s is not as fast as the
gfx 100 yeah it's actually still
considered fast in the medium format
world it is yes it is i mean that's the
thing i think when you put in single
autofocus it's quick um i i did notice
improvement over the when i first tried
the 50s and the 50r
uh back in its day i mean it does
respond well when you go to continuous
autofocus
it hunts yeah it's a little bit
fluttering back and forth and that's
where you see with that contrast detect
system kind of not as
i would say
that's the word i'm terrified it was not
as
certain certain yes not as certain as
phase detect
but yeah you know that's the thing for
me is because i when i've tried you know
i've been shooting with the 100s for a
while and i'm like do i need 100
megapixels and i like it the fact that
you have the you have it
oh man i have to buy more storage on my
computers and all that stuff i mean
that's right that's something you have
to think of taking into consideration
because you know a day or two of
shooting
you load that up each image is around
200 megabytes a shot raw that's right
you can you can press and bring it down
but still
it's a lot of storage you need a lot of
storage for such things where this is
considerably smaller
so i think maybe this camera is market
for somebody who wants to upgrade
you could be using an x series and you
upgrade you don't need 100 right so you
can upgrade to a medium format yeah you
don't need to shoot sports if you're not
a sports photographer that's fine right
yeah if you shoot portraits landscape
some lifestyle picture with portraits
fashion i think it's perfectly fine
right but not for sports obviously no
not for sports even 100s for sports is
really not it's not meant for it no i
mean you can capture some shots here and
there yeah with the right lighting if
you want to do some quick strobe shots
whatever but it's not designed to like
compete with the full frame marker it's
just not there it's only perfect for
sports portraits there we go
[Laughter]
i like that yeah okay so um
i guess that's kind of the 50s too in a
nutshell i mean it's not like it would
say a revolutionary camera i mean price
point it is but but in terms of design
and features i mean a couple things i
did notice missing in the camera system
is that there's no performance boost for
epf
that you would see in uh the gfx100s
because one of the nice things that
fujifilm systems does have which i
appreciate is that you get this option
to sort of enhance certain aspects of
the camera if it's focusing in low light
or focusing or evf boost to sort of get
the higher frame rate depending on the
situation you're in yeah you know the
50s too
don't you're missing some of those
features and i mean i guess also due to
technology as well right probably i'm
not very sure about that but i guess
it's just to differentiate the
difference between the two systems yeah
yeah just like when it came out this kit
lens which is like 499 yeah so many
been asking is it as good as the 3264
uh they are different first of all price
points is a huge difference yeah yeah
not that it's a bad lens it says that
this is a great lens right but the size
again look at the size difference it's
actually a lot of difference i mean yeah
i mean when you extend this out yeah
it's still longer and i mean it's
considerably heavier on this and then
aperture is obviously different as well
that's an f4 straight across yeah this
is 4.5 that's 5.6
so you know you are getting a big
difference in that regard of that i mean
this is a great kit lens and in terms of
build quality in case you're wondering
yes because of the price point does it
feel as good as the 3264 yes probably
not but it doesn't feel that cheap i
mean it doesn't it's not like a light
it's a lot lighter but it doesn't feel
like a cheap kit lens so if that's what
you're worried about don't be um i've
had some friends that were asking me
about this based on the rumors are like
have you seen it i'm like i can't say
anything i have to sign my life away you
know but uh
you know they were always worried about
that build quality aspect of it but it
looks like i like it when you close it
up it's actually quite
short it is right yeah and it's nice to
pack it put into a bag carry around it's
a good walk around lens for me i like it
in a sense but in terms of sharpness
between the two i compare it of course
this is a sharper lens not like that's
bad but this is
really sharp all right so i mean
obviously if you have the best of the
best and then you know this you're going
to notice a difference yeah it's a kit
lens yeah
yeah but it's a good entry camera if
somebody wants to come in and try medium
format if you buy the gfx 50
s mark ii i would definitely get this
lens it's a must-have i mean 500 bucks
you might as well right at least you
have something you know i mean
but then of course we want to talk a
little bit lenses for a moment right we
got here the 110 and the 120. yeah this
is the 110 and 120 macro yeah yeah these
are two very sharp lens great bouquet
and 100 to 200 yeah i mean this is the
magical lens yeah this is the one lens i
think if you get into a gfx system
this is the one lens to get
you see like this is 110 and this 120. i
own both of these lens i know like why
you know like this is for me this is
great for outdoor yeah portraits yes
because there is a minimum focusing
distance perfect but if you want to do a
beauty shot in the studio then this is
tech sharp you like it you like the
macro for beauty shots yeah in the
studio because i can go closer like
maybe
right half body shot shot i got you
where else the 110 couldn't do that no
but you get the beautiful fall off the
beautiful bokeh on this yes it just is
stunning for skin tones it is it's
magical it is magical it's a magical
lens
but anyway so i guess what we can do now
um because we can do some comparison
shots so if you guys want to see this
we'll put this up here with the 100 and
the 50 s2 and we'll put them next to
each other i mean for those of you
who've never shot with these cameras
before and we can just kind of show you
a little bit we'll zoom in on those
images zacky we can do some of that
right yes yeah
yeah pretty good with this stuff screen
mode look at that
professional editor there
split screen mode we'll do that we'll
kind of compare some shots i'm going to
shoot some stuff right here around the
studio as well because
we've got some really cool things here
the geek cultures do first time here
right exactly i'm amazed it's like a
little museum
yeah yeah i brought a big bag out here
today maybe i'll pick some home later
there we go
i don't know if we would miss anything
there's a little bit of redundancy
happening here
all right guys so what we'll do is we'll
take some pictures and we'll come back
and
just wrap things up here
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
all right so we just showed you guys
some photos taken here in the studio as
well as some of ivan's photos with the
50s mark ii and some with the 3570 of
course versus the 3264 and macro shots
ivan what's your thoughts on this uh kit
lens
i think the quality will definitely not
match the 3264 no you're not going to
see the full potential of the sensor
that's right with this lens obviously we
shot wide open it's quite soft uh close
up i mean obviously does sharpen up as
you stop down yes but at 5.6 at 70
millimeters uh it was
yeah it was soft yeah and there is some
purple fringing happening there as well
so uh something to take note of but
now let's talk about
100 versus 50. is there a difference
we showed some images just now yeah but
your thoughts
100 megapixels is definitely a lot more
megapixel we can punch in all the way to
the maximum 100 for 50 100 can function
another level in so it's actually more
forgiving if you're doing serious work
it will help you a long way
so if you ask me
um but would you spend 2 000 more
dollars that's the question why did you
spend it i would spend two downloads
more to get a hundred for me i would for
work right
and
would i get a backup camera for 50
i might though i think it's quite fun
having a 50 and 100 together as a set
instead of getting 100 because there are
times i don't need a hundred right right
yeah i know what you mean yeah i mean
it's the hundreds come in handy for me
is a couple times when i was uh doing
some photo shoots i was doing one for a
friend of mine for a watch uh kind of a
social media campaign
and i wasn't able to get too close to
him because we were on a boat so i had
to get us quite a bit of distance i was
using the 45 100
and because he needed a shot of the
watch close up from only the watched
only the one well him and then the
second shot was the watch close up
on a 50 megapixel i would not be able to
crop in that much yet as much as you can
crop it on 50 i wouldn't be able to do
it
but with the 100 i was able to and it
was still good enough for social media
so that's when i was like okay i get the
power of the hundred megapixel it's not
gonna be something you're gonna use
every day
because most of the time on social media
i'm downsizing my images to like 2500
pixels on the long side just to post it
up so i don't get any compression
and you know you're not going to you
know utilize all that but you do get
that sharpness you do get that detail
and of course 16 bit color yes it makes
a difference which does make a big
difference especially when you're
editing skin tones or doing makeup or
you're doing professional shoots um now
i'm going to throw something to you and
this is the question so now i'm going to
play a double devil's advocate with the
ivan here and
as i mentioned earlier in this video
2016 sensor it's now 20 21.
is this camera at the price point of 4
000 us dollars still relevant
with
cameras like
r5
alpha one
uh
a7r4 z72 i mean
which has which they all have phase
detect autofocus yes you know
they're smaller
what do you think
actually there's no comparison between a
minimum format and a full frame i feel
because
it's just like if you say a micro four
third is as good as a aps-c or asaps is
as good as a full frame
or
full frame is as good as a medium format
right or a gfx100s is better than a
phase one they're all completely
different they're different kind of
animals
but if you look at a 50s by itself i
think that
you have to consider the sensor
and the glass that comes through it it's
a packaged right right it's not just the
body alone because you can use a full
frame 50 megapixel 45 60 the glass and
combine it together
the result yield is there will be a
difference because the glass is still a
notch higher compared to the full frame
true yeah the question is at this price
point like i mentioned it's five years
old in terms of sensor
but i still relevant in this time of age
because the glass is a whole combi okay
yeah and if you don't do sports i think
it's still a great camera
commercial world is still fine okay you
don't need that larger size right but
for me if you need that if you can
afford that two thousand dollars more i
will go for this yeah but of course if i
have a second camera i would go for this
too to add on to it as a package oh wow
that's that's that's uh yeah that's a
that's a big chunk out of the bank
account
that's a big chunk no but i mean fair
points i mean that's and i think that's
really where it comes down to is the
glass is the big deciding factor and i
think that's something where a lot of
full-frame companies they haven't made
glass to really resolve 100 megapixels
yet yeah 50 60 so forth but you buy a
lens like this
you know
this is going to last you for quite some
time even if this
sensor let's say in a year or two they
move away from the 50 or they get a new
50. yeah
you're still going to be able to resolve
more out of this lens definitely than i
would say yeah yeah
this time so there you have it ivan
thank you so much for coming by my
pleasure sharing with us of course the
50s mark ii and this 3570 and
all the other
beautiful toys
this is a very expensive table we have
here right now this is an expensive
table huh yeah yeah there's a lot of
yeah yeah probably 30 thousand i think
singapore else
let's not drop anything hopefully
all right with that guys uh thanks for
watching this if you liked the video
like subscribe to our channel follow us
on facebook
and uh also follow ivan what's your
instagram handle at fujifanboys yes he
is the man behind fujifanboys and also
your blog as well which you do a lot of
reviews yes i do what's the name of it
ivan joshua all right with that guys
take care stay safe and chat to the next
one bye
[Music]